it's the show set before during and
after a pandemic that was shot before
during and well hopefully we'll get to
the after hbo station 11 is a
post-apocalyptic mini-series based off
the book by emily saint john mandel and
i don't think i've seen a show since
netflix is the oa which has left me with
so many unanswered questions so
naturally i wanted to tackle this epic
tale which spans more than 20 years and
get to the bottom of what exactly is
station 11. the final episode opens on
miranda carroll the author of station 11
a graphic novel which has taken her
years to write the novel itself is a
byproduct of trauma as a child miranda
and her family were stuck in a hurricane
when a live wire electrocuted everyone
but her she was saved because she just
so happened to be coloring on the
countertop away from the water it's no
wonder then that when arthur leander
interprets one of her drawings that we
see the book's protagonist a spaceman
named dr eleven is really a metaphor for
miranda herself in episode 3 arthur
leander describes the doctor as alone
but not unhappy adrift and exhausted but
because he wears a suit people don't
realize what a warm and light heart he
has this is essentially describing
miranda it's just that instead of a
spacesuit that she wears she protects
herself by being distant but even when
you're here
you're not here miranda leaves arthur
right before the flu that will kill 99.9
percent of people on earth it's her
biggest regret
why wasn't i with my love
when he died
she's halfway around the world in
malaysia when we flash back a few days
earlier to young kirsten miranda and
arthur backstage at the theater where
arthur performs king lear
who's that he's the [ __ ] the draw in
my life kirsten obtains one of only five
copies of station 11 and this book will
end up shaping her life whereas the book
was born of trauma it becomes a beacon
of hope for kirsten and although the
story is a fictitious tale about a space
man drifting alone through space to be
found and saved again it's ultimately a
tale about universal truths that
although we may be damaged and escape
that damage there is hope that one day
we'll be reunited with those we love as
miranda dies from the flu she receives a
call from clark thompson one of arthur's
friends informing her that arthur has
died but the universe has a strange way
of working out clark just happened to be
on the same flight as arthur's wife
elizabeth and son tyler not only that
but the pilot of the gichagumi a plane
still on the tarmac at the severn city
airport where clark is stranded happens
to have the same name as the hurricane
that killed miranda's family in fact he
was named after it she's able to track
down the pilot's cell number and tells
them to lock the passengers inside there
is no rescue mission coming and if those
infected with the flu get out they'll
infect those safe within the airport
this all leads to one of the defining
moments in the series days after all the
passengers aboard the gichigumi are
believed to be dead tyler sees a
survivor emerge and brings him into the
airport believing him to be immune and
no threat to the others this ends up
with the man being shot and clark
uttering the words
we are not monsters and that word
monsters can be found in the novel where
dr eleven exclaims to the monsters we
are the monsters and this is uttered
throughout the series the monsters
we're the monsters for those survivors
at the airport the monsters are those
infected in the gichigumi and should be
exterminated but for the passengers in
the gitugumi the monsters are those that
held them on the tarmac each sees each
other as the monster this analogy is
echoed to jiven by young kirsten when
they hunt wolves to the monsters we're
the monsters
what does that mean we see wolves as
monsters because they attack us but they
see us as monsters because we attack
them this actually plays out when jeevan
is mauled by a wolf named big daddy in
episode 9. the killing of the innocent
guccigumi passenger is arguably one of
the biggest turning points for tyler he
sees life before the flu as traumatic
and any attempt to get civilization back
to the way it was should be stopped for
example when the topic of repopulating
the earth comes up he says maybe we
shouldn't though
repopulate and when he suggests deleting
the last article he downloaded from the
internet before it went down an article
that describes capitalism his mother
says we just invented again so when
clark becomes the de facto leader of the
airport and decides to turn it into a
museum honoring the achievements of the
before times tyler isn't having it
although there's much more to tyler's
decision here he ends up faking his own
death by lighting the gitjugumi on fire
most of the series takes place 20 years
after the pandemic as we follow adult
kirsten and a group known as the
traveling symphony they travel around
lake michigan performing shakespeare to
various communities littered around the
lake but there's a lot of interesting
elements that are all converging at this
one point at the airport first we have
adult tyler now known as the prophet
he's used the station 11 book to
brainwash a group of kids acting as a
sort of cult leader as he told alex in
episode 4 he believes those born after
the pandemic are special the first human
generation to be rid from trauma
the survivors were the only liars left
he even gets them to be used as child
soldiers who suicide bomb at his bidding
but in his eyes he's not the monster
he's doing good it all goes back to the
line from the book to the monsters we
are the monsters at the same time sarah
the traveling symphony's composer has a
heart attack this forces elizabeth to
call a doctor who just happens to be
jeevan the man who cared for kirsten
during the first year of the pandemic
but was separated from her after his
wolf attack jimin has gone on his own
personal journey starting off as a man
who suffered from panic attacks and
couldn't connect with children to one
who has a family and remains calm even
in the face of death he would learn to
become a doctor from deborah who says
the hardest part of being a doctor isn't
knowing all the science it's the courage
to bear witness to death
the courage
to be there and this is exactly what
jeevan does when he is there for sarah
at her death fun fact saint debra is the
name of the first town the traveling
symphony plays and it's named after
debra who delivered multiple babies in
one night during the first year of the
pandemic so now we have kirsten tyler
jeevan and the traveling symphony all in
one place for a performance of hamlet
and to make things even more meta tyler
will play the role of hamlet his actual
mother that of gertrude hamlet's mother
and clark claudius the usurper who
killed hamlet's father so when i say
things are meta it gets even more crazy
for example the play hamlet features a
play within it the murder of gonzago and
now we're watching a tv show that has a
play within a play that takes place
after a pandemic while we ourselves are
facing our own pandemic it's pretty wild
while tyler is captured kirsten tells
him to look at a specific scene from
hamlet act 3 scene 4 which is all about
hamlet confronting his mother about
marrying his father's brother it gets at
tyler's innermost feeling of betrayal
meanwhile clark has put a stop to the
play believing that a rendition of
hamlet a show which is about a man
rebelling against authority may give the
impressionable youth ideas but when he
finds out kirsten is the same girl he
met 20 years ago backstage at king lear
he lets them go on with the show with
him in the role as claudius it's what
arthur would have wanted the play goes
on and tyler is given kirsten's knife to
kill clark on stage this knife was the
same one that killed jeevan's brother
frank in chicago years ago tyler ends up
not going through with it do not forever
with thy veiled lids seek for thy noble
father in the dust all that lives
must die
passing through nature to eternity not
only are these gertrude's real lines in
act one of hamlet but her way of telling
her son that he can't spend his whole
life with his eyes to the ground
remembering his father that what lives
must die eventually passing to eternity
tyler realizes this and will end up
leaving with his mother and army of kids
at the after party the musicians sing
midnight train to georgia which may be a
slight nod to the book since the flu in
station 11 is called the georgia flu
it's here we also get the heartfelt
reunion between kirsten and jeevan they
don't even say a word to each other in
the scene just embrace and the series
ends with the traveling symphony
venturing off to their next town kirsten
and jeevan say goodbye she even talks
about how a long time ago he met a girl
and walked her home it's a play on words
not only did he walk kirsten home 20
years ago but she is now in a place
where she has a home if it weren't for
jeevan she would have never found it he
even says as they get to the crossroads
there goes your family and she agrees
even though these two characters went
through so much damage they found each
other and their home as the station 11
book says i have found you nine times
before maybe ten although we may go our
separate ways as depicted by the
crossroads here there is always a way
back another time where we'll meet again
and you might have a different
interpretation of this ending it's
purposely ambiguous in episode 8 frank
asks kirsten what happens at the end of
the novel but kirsten replies that the
story ends before we find out kind of
like the show we don't know where tyler
will end up what's next for kirsten or
what will happen to jeevan's family all
we know is that they've found each other
many times before and will probably see
each other again the argument frank ends
up making is that the ending the author
wants you to see doesn't matter it's the
journey in your own interpretation
that's important while the ending of
station 11 is pretty open-ended it still
gives us some cathartic moments and hope
that these characters will see each
other again thanks for watching everyone
please be sure to like and subscribe and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much